These eight business owners are
competing for $100,000 and this golden
ticket, which gives them access to an
entire year of guidance from myself and
the team behind my $250 million per year
portfolio. They each have 60 minutes
with me to explain their business and by
the end, I'll decide if they scale or
fail. For those who are chosen to scale,
I'll give them a personalized 90-day
blueprint on how to grow their business
and 90 days later, whoever grows the
most wins and walks away with the grand
prize.
My name is Alex Hormozi and I've been in
business for 15 [music] years and I
recently broke the Guinness World Record
for the fastest-selling nonfiction book
of all time, making over $106 million in
a weekend. And this is Scale or Fail.
>> My name is [music] Nass. I'm the founder
of Flex 100 Moving and Delivery.
We're based out of San Diego,
California. The journey to this business
was very accidental. I was a broke
college student athlete. My friend from
Austin came up one time and he just said
you should be making some extra money
and all it takes is just posting an ad
online.
>> [music]
>> Took me about 11 months out of fear to
post my first ad.
From there, I just realized how much you
can grow this business and what's
actually possible to do.
I found out about the Scale and Workshop
here in Acquisition.com and I came in
2025 [music]
and since then the journey to this has
been growing. Growing this business is
really important [music] to me. I just
want to show myself that I could
actually do this.
Good morning, Alex.
>> Good morning, man.
>> How are you doing?
>> Good.
>> Great to see you.
>> Good to see you, too, man. So, tell me
about the business.
>> My name is Nass. I'm 29.
Um I'm the founder of Flex 100 Moving
and Delivery. We did about $300,000 over
the last 12 months, profit being 62%.
Our goal is really to expand to um
multiple locations with um 2 to 4
million dollars per location in the next
2 to 3 years.
We'd love to paint the map pink with our
pink trucks.
>> Walk me through the the business model.
>> Most of our business come through local
residential moves that represents about
90% of the revenue. We charge based on
an hourly rate. It's $165 for two
professional movers plus $150 for the
truck and equipment.
>> Are you the cheapest?
>> No, absolutely not.
>> You're the most expensive?
>> Up there.
>> Okay. And how do you get customers?
>> So, being the second highest and best
rated moving company in San Diego, as
you can see, like most of the revenue
would be from Google Maps and SEO. It's
kind of like organic. Um cost about
$1,000 to $1,200 a month for SEO.
And the main winner right now that we've
been testing with would be the realtor
outreach.
>> Tell me about this realtor thing.
>> So, we'd reach out to them and then we'd
tell them, "Hey, if you have anybody
like moving out, we'll give them that
little offer of like anybody over
$2,000, then we will, you know, give
them $250 off them." So, for the
realtors, the job is like they pay so
much. For example, this month out of out
of 17 jobs on Google, we made $16,000.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. And out of
six jobs with realtors, we made $15,000.
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's over $3,000 per job with
realtors compared to any other channel.
>> Okay. Anything else that's stopping you
from scaling?
>> Just not enough leads. Uh we could
easily double up the business, but as of
right now, it's just not enough leads.
>> Okay. Why do you even want to grow the
business to begin with? Like, you're
already making money, right?
>> There's different reasons. Number one is
that my wife just quit her six-figure
job about five days ago to bet on me.
>> [laughter]
>> I know you heard that a lot, but this
one is real.
So, she quit her job. She's betting on
me. She trusts me on doing this. I'm not
going to let her down.
>> Okay.
>> And then two, I've had guys that have
been working with me for the last few
years.
And these guys, all they're asking for
is just stable work so they can feed
their families. Three would be my mom,
who worked extremely hard for us to be
here coming from Morocco. Her only dream
in life is to own a house. And I would
be the reason make that, you know, dream
a reality.
My mom has worked extremely hard [music]
her entire life, uh
you know, for me and my sister to be
where we are today.
My mom's [music] only dream is to just
own her own house.
Which does not even require much. It's
quarter of a million dollars, 250,000.
I could possibly regret that forever
if I don't work harder enough [music] to
just
get her that little thing that she has
dreamed about. I I really [music] don't
care.
I don't care for a house. I don't care
for a car. I just care for that cuz I
it's in me for me to pay back uh
people that have stuck with me when I
needed it the most. And if anything,
she's the only person.
Last but not least, it's kind of like a
little bit personal. People that have
been against us, it's not really to show
them that they're wrong, but just to
prove myself that I could go a lot
further.
>> you're right.
>> Yeah, sure. [laughter]
>> No, I dig it. Okay, cool. This seems
pretty straightforward. I've got a I've
got a handful of things that I think we
can do.
So, let me just walk you through how I
how I kind of think of this large-scale.
So, I think we'll we'll start with the
offer, all right?
And then I want to work on the
sales process a little.
And then
we'll talk about this realtor's thing.
And then we'll go
traffic.
So, if you think about fixing a
business, I always fix things from back
to front. So, it's like the thing you
sell, how we sell it, who we're going to
sell it to, and how we get them to find
out about it, right? Okay, if we're
talking like big picture basically, you
will become a commodity if you're using
the exact same measured unit, right?
You're like cuz they're they're just
asking, "What's the hourly?" I'm
guessing a lot of people you get on the
phone, right?
>> What's the price? Yes.
>> Right. And so, I think if I were you, I
would break that frame and just say, "We
don't do it by hourly. We just do it by
job."
And I can give you an estimate because
at the end of the day, cuz how someone
might respond back, "Well, I just need
to know what the hourly." It's like, "I
could have the guy drag ass and take all
day." You'd rather get done quickly
rather than take a long time, right? And
you want it done well. Well, that's what
we'll do.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz that'll get you out of this kind of
like it's 120 here and they're at 125.
It's just like it doesn't matter cuz
they could take 8 hours and I could take
four.
>> Yes.
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> The only issues with that is that a lot
of these people would like to tell you
what they have and you can't really
estimate that if you do a flat rate.
>> Think about like this, like
in order to scale the business
long-term, it's like we want to have
something unique
that's that's somewhat right if we can.
Now, if we're also selling a
commoditized product, which is just
sheer labor right now plus a truck,
there's not a lot of differentiators
there besides maybe like pink. I'm
trying to think of a way to get you out
of the hourly race if possible. Look,
cuz right now you're servicing kind of
the lower end of the market, right? If
you're if you're servicing renters and
kind of smaller homes. Because like I'll
tell you, when I moved
I honestly have no idea what I paid, but
I'm guessing it's probably in the
neighborhood of like $25,000. I have no
clue. But the idea was I'm going to
leave my house and then I'm going to
show up at the other house and it's
done.
That was what happened.
>> Yeah, that's for the rich.
>> Yeah. No, exactly. Well, have you heard
my stuff?
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
>> You know where the money is?
>> Yeah, yeah, exactly. Sell to the rich.
>> Right. And so my point is not like I'm
not saying you all of a sudden overnight
become ultra diamond, you know,
whatever. But if you what you realized
was the realtors
it's not that the realtors are special,
it's that they're get you got a taste of
selling to people who have more money.
>> Of course.
>> Right. And so you made way more profit
on those deals than you did on the on
the kind of generic. And so that's why I
asked about the offer because to me
there should be a white glove
offer. To me, that's what's missing.
>> Mhm.
>> So I thought about that. I did it. Um it
worked.
>> Mhm.
>> It worked a couple times, but then I
kind of just turned it off.
>> Okay.
>> Why?
Cuz it wasn't selling well.
>> Okay, that's fine. Then the offer wasn't
good. So
I'm not I'm not thrilled right now.
Um
>> [laughter]
>> cuz you're just like I'm a little bit
more expensive and people get a little
bit more value than they would with
other people and it's very hard to
claim anything that's different besides
the trucks being pink and the guys being
better.
>> And no hidden fees.
>> Sure.
>> Cuz material is included like shrink
wrap and moving buckets and all that
stuff is included compared to other
companies they would just throw an extra
$600 at the end of the bill and you have
to pay for it cuz you have absolutely no
option. But they don't tell you that.
>> Mhm.
>> Until it's done. But people still see
the hourly rate to be cheaper somewhere
else it's what's going to save the day.
>> No, I know. I know. I know.
Don't love it. I'm going to shift gears.
Let's talk about this realtor thing.
So, why don't we say let's just for for
fun for shits and giggles, right?
>> Yeah.
>> You can have a VIP moving level, right?
And then you have your standard moving
level. I think that the realtors would
be better served. They probably don't
care about the $250 cuz if they sold
that house then they made way more than
that it's irrelevant. They want the
referral and they want the people to
know that it was a great experience.
And so I think you probably get way more
referrals if you said I'll give
everybody who you send a VIP service for
the price of standard. That will
probably mean more to them than getting
$250.
>> Oh.
>> And then for them they'll be able to be
like, "Hey, if you go through me he'll
give you the the VIP level service at
the at the standard rate."
>> Got it.
>> To me I think that's a lot more
compelling.
>> But what would the VIP be? Just what we
create?
>> Yes, let's make it up.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Yeah, that makes
sense.
>> [laughter]
>> In the cloud.
>> Yeah, well I mean you could have offered
unpacking and if everybody says no then
that's that, right? Like it's like we'll
even unpack it and then people might
just opt out. If you know most people do
then it's great. It's almost like a
false offer.
>> Okay.
>> Because you know more about the the
customer than they do which is the whole
point.
>> Or the VIP could be I can give you like
movers with 10 plus years of moving
experience that would take care of this
entirely.
>> Only reason I don't like that is from a
model perspective that'll be more
difficult to scale. And I don't know how
much that will matter.
So, I'll tell you a different version of
this, which is like instead of doing 10
years, it'd be like every mover has over
50 moves.
>> Okay.
>> And so, I'll give you an example. So,
like when I had my trainers at my gyms,
anyone can be a trainer. Literally
anyone can be. Like you, I have
low-skilled labor.
And then you can have a certified
trainer, which they go through
accreditations versus not. And you can
also internally certify.
>> Mhm.
>> And so, what I did is I created three
levels of internal certification. I'd be
like, you're going to have a level three
master trainer.
>> Mhm.
>> Most people are like, oh wow, that's
awesome. But it's just like they just
had to do some stuff. And for me, a
level three was like they'd done a
thousand sessions.
>> Fair enough.
>> Or whatever. And so, for you, you can be
like you have a level three mover. So,
we have different moving movers
different for different skill levels.
And so, you'll have all level three
movers. Cuz what you're trying to do,
when you're selling a commodity, you're
basically sowing seeds of doubt against
the competition. So, part of what you
said was, well, they're charging 120 an
hour, but that's because they're going
to nickel and dime me over here. I'm not
going to do that. That's basically
sowing some seed of doubt saying, I'm
actually different. Right? That's
basically what you're doing. You're
saying, we're not the same.
>> Yeah.
>> Basically, how many other things can we
do there?
So, we have speed, risk, and ease. Like
so, speed, since you're charging hourly,
is probably not going to be the thing.
Now, you could do speed in terms of like
we can come tomorrow.
But they probably have a moving day that
they like are planned out doing.
>> A lot of times you do a last minute
moves, and we charge a couple of little
bit. Yeah. Oh, yeah, people call like
today for today. It's like my movers
bailed on me, and that's the reason why
a lot of people would go with cheaper
movers, and then
>> Do you have a same-day premium?
>> Um not premium. We kind of like to avoid
this.
>> no, no.
>> Yeah, cuz like cuz sometimes they're so
desperate for a job, so I'm like, yeah,
whatever. I'll I'll just take it, you
know.
I know. I
>> [laughter]
>> Got it. Okay.
>> Um
>> Um okay, so you have the fee that that
that other people are nickel and diming.
And then so, then another a kind of seed
of doubt, right? So, there's risk,
speed, and ease. Right? And so, what
we're hitting on with this kind of like
master mover, if you will. Actually
sounds kind of nice, master mover. Is
the risk component. Which is, listen,
believe it or not, a lot of my
competitors, they can win on price cuz
they're just literally going to take
someone off the street. When I say
literally, I mean literally. And then
you don't know if they have a record,
you don't know like what's going on,
right? None of my guys are, you know,
ex-cons and on Your Move for VIP, you
get all level three master movers who've
done at least 50 moves or 100 moves.
Whatever, make make whatever you want,
right? So, how does that sound in terms
of the VIP? It's going to be around
risk. So, it's like we're going to have
this higher tier of mover
and uh no there's no extra thing besides
the labor and we're going to include all
the materials.
>> If you do full-service moves, that's
like packing and unpacking. I love that
a lot.
>> Okay. So, that to me is what you give
these guys, the realtors,
and you already use master movers as is,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, there's really no change between
that and standard. It's just that if you
have standard, you have the option of
using cheaper movers. If all your guys
are already equipped master movers, then
great. So, I'll just go here, but
basically our VIP,
right, is going to be pack
plus master, you know, master movers
plus material.
And then standard,
I would say it's still pack,
but it's just not master movers plus
anyone.
So, that's probably not too big of a
cost for you.
>> For me, no.
>> Okay, perfect. Well, then that's about
the $250, but this feels significantly
more premium
than just doing a 250 bucks off or 250
back to the realtor.
>> Okay.
>> Do you like that better?
>> I love that a lot.
>> Okay. So, also when you're when you're
getting on the phone, I think you can
just basically have these
these tiers. Now, I would start with
VIP.
>> That's how you would sell it.
>> Yeah.
>> To anybody or just
>> No, I would do it to everybody. I always
start high.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz the thing is is when you get on the
phone with somebody who has money, they
don't care.
They just want it done.
>> Yes, I agree.
>> And so, you have to give that up that
person the opportunity to buy. Now, as
soon as someone says, "No, I'm on a
budget." You're like, "No worries, then
just do standard."
>> Perfect.
>> So, most people use this, but if you're
on a budget, we have this. And then if
someone still objects, then you
basically have to walk down the seeds of
doubt. So, I
this feels like it's worth diving into a
little bit. The issue that you brought
up is that Yelp you didn't like and Ads
you didn't like, right?
>> Right. So, to me that's not a leads
issue, it's a sales process issue.
>> Okay.
>> So, we have to make you different in
some way compared to everybody else.
Okay. So, we have our factors. So, we
have Master Movers, we have that, we
have materials, we have that. Do you
have insurance or anything like that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Do you talk about it?
>> insured.
Yeah. I mean, as an operator moving
company, you're supposed to have license
and insurance.
>> Great.
Great. These are These are These are
elements, right? We We need We need
components to the offer, right? Cuz they
Again, think risk. So, this is risk,
this is ease, this is risk. What else do
we have? We have speed.
So, I do think that if someone does same
day,
you can just say we have a same day
surcharge of 10%.
>> Okay.
>> Just cuz I want you to get used to
charging it, because speed is one of the
biggest things people pay for. If
someone had someone back out,
and they need something to be moved
today,
that's when you can charge.
>> Yeah.
>> Right? And this might not sound like
much, but again, when you hit 20
locations, this will add up. Because
your margins aren't going to be 70%. You
might be at 30, and all of a sudden a
10% lift, or 20% lift, all of a sudden
you're like, "Oh, shit." And it's all
margin.
>> Yeah.
>> Right?
So, I'll say a date premium, start at
10%, but I want you to go to 20% over
time.
And you can basically keep moving up
until they say no. So, these are
different components. We have our A, we
have B, we have C. See, we're getting
We're getting little pieces that we can
talk on the phone, right?
>> I have not tapped into every single
piece of this business. I'm not even
capped out yet. I haven't even done the
obvious stuff that other businesses are
doing.
Um that's why I think I really have a
huge advantage that we could grow the
most. And that's really the only
advantage that we have is that we're
small enough to scale the most.
>> Okay. What about a cap?
>> Meaning?
>> It's not going to cost more than this.
Let's say they do an estimate.
>> Yeah.
>> How likely is it that they're off by 2x?
>> Not by 2x, no.
>> Okay.
>> But at least a 30%.
>> Okay. So, I mean, what if we say 50%?
So, I'm saying I want to give you a
buffer. I'll tell you why I'm saying
this. If you get on the phone and say,
"Hey, did the other guys give you a
cap?" And they'll be like, "No."
And you're like, "Oh." Well, yeah,
that's how they're going to get you. And
then they're like, "Wait, what?" And
you're like, "Oh, yeah. I mean, like, I
can just take 20 hours to to move one
thing from here to there. There's not
much you can do when somebody's on
site."
And they're like, "Oh, I didn't really
think about that." It's like, right. So,
we'll be this, and we won't exceed this.
>> Got it. Okay.
>> Unless there's a huge issue when we
arrive on site, but that's basically I
agree the type person who's going to be
lying about this. No, okay, great. Then
it's fine. So, it will not be more than
this.
>> Got it. Okay.
>> And then that way, cuz again, we're
trying to sow seeds of doubt. Like, if
they have two things and they're both
100 hour 90 an hour, they're going to
pick the 90.
>> Of course, yeah.
>> So, we have to be like, "Oh, okay, got
it. So, what insurance do the other guys
Oh, they didn't mention. Oh, yeah. Well,
for sure, if you're uninsured, then
yeah, I mean, that's that's a cost, but
I'm assuming is nothing you have
valuable?"
>> Uh, you know, like,
>> "No, I have I have some valuable things
that matter to me." It's like, great.
Well, we have insurance um that we can
include. Do you know what I'm saying
with with this sale here?
>> Yeah, it's going to come It's going to
come down.
>> Yeah, and we're going to We had to get
this part here so that when we move to
the sales process,
>> brain is going like all over.
>> Yeah, yeah. I hear you.
Okay. But fundamentally, cuz this is
going to ladder into this, but we have
our VIP, and we have our standard. We're
going to start everyone here.
>> Yeah.
>> And then we're going to If they say,
"I'm on a budget," we'll say, "No
worries. We can do this for you."
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
You all right?
>> Yeah, yeah, it's opening up my mind.
>> All right. So, sales process. So,
you were able to talk to all the people
who came in on the on the Google leads,
right?
>> Yes, everybody.
Immediately.
>> The main objection we have is always
price.
>> It's always price if they don't know
what else to talk about. Customers will
always go to price if you don't give
them any other variables to consider.
>> Okay.
>> And this is what we're trying to do.
Like, that's the point of the offers
book. It's like, how do I How do I break
these two things of price and value?
>> Yeah.
>> Right? If if there's apples and apples,
you want apples and oranges. And even
though you build the same way, we it
like fine, I get that. Can we still make
it different enough on all these other
things that they're like, [__] I didn't
even think about that.
>> Yeah.
>> So, when someone when someone calls in,
what's the first question you ask them?
>> The day of the move. When are they
moving? Just to make sure we have
availability.
>> Okay. So, you ask for the day, and then
let's say that you're empty. Now what?
>> Now, I do ask how much stuff they're
looking to move. Like, what's the size
of the move?
>> Okay. And you say the size of your
what's the square footage of your stuff
or what?
>> No, how many rooms? We go by the rooms.
Like, is it a one-bedroom, two-bedroom?
And then the time is For example, it's a
two-bedroom. I'm like, great. Like, what
are we looking to move?
>> Yeah.
>> And then I ask stairs or no stairs just
to have an idea like like how long the
job will take, and then where the truck
is going to be parked.
>> We still want to walk through these
other pieces, which is okay, got it. Do
you care about the the qualifications of
the movers that you have?
They're like, I never thought about
that. You're like, oh, okay, cuz a lot
of the guys uh they have like ex-cons.
Some people are like very uncomfortable
with that. Believe it or not, it's
actually 20% of the industry. I put some
stats, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Um all right, so yeah.
>> No, no, for sure. Right? So, it's like,
do you care about the Well, I don't want
ex-cons in my house. And you're like,
great. So, and you're you're in your
mind you're like, okay, they want master
movers. You're like, okay, so um do you
already have all the materials?
To get all this stuff packed up and all
that? Oh, no, you don't? Okay.
>> Packing.
>> Got it, right? And you're like, okay.
You're like, got it. So, do you have
anything that's valued over $500?
>> Obviously, yes.
>> And they say yeah, and you're like,
okay.
>> Insurance.
>> You're just listening, right? Yeah, and
you're like, okay. Now, is this isn't
today. So, if it was if if it was today,
then we'd include the day premium. If
it's not, then we're like, okay, got it.
So, this is what we can do. We're 165 an
hour, and if you go with us today, I'll
include the master movers, I'll include
materials, and I'll include the
insurance.
>> If they do full if they do a full full
service like packing. If we get packed
with them, then we can include the
materials for free. So, that is the
offer you were talking about earlier.
>> Okay.
>> And if they're like, "Oh, I can't do
that." Then it's like, "Okay, we can
still do it, but we're going to be at
standard. What's your I don't If this is
going to be the new VIP, make this one
95, make this one 65. Whatever." Okay.
Uh so this is VIP, and this is going to
be standard, right?
You like that?
>> Yeah, I love it.
That's fantastic. It's awesome.
>> Cuz that way that way again, we're
already having a conversation with more
detail.
>> Mhm.
>> I just want to give you bullets so that
again, we want to get on the phones cuz
how many
How many are you losing to price?
>> A lot. Like 40%.
>> Yeah. Okay. So So this is important.
Right. So we want to make sure that they
don't think that they're getting the
same thing for less. We want them to
know they're getting way less for less.
>> So the way we've been selling is that if
they kind of hit us with the price
issue, I'm like, "Hey, if you find
anybody in this industry in San Diego
right now that would match our reviews,
we'll beat their price." And cuz they
don't exist. But I can't That's not
>> but that's not They're like, "Yeah, but
whatever. Yeah, yeah, yeah."
If you can find somebody else that does
insurance, has has level three movers,
uh includes materials, you know, it has
a cap, by all means uh I'll I'll price
match it. But like, I've never been in
the price matching game my whole life.
I'd rather just be in the value
surpassing game.
Which is if these things matter to you,
we're the only shop in town that does
it. If you don't care about having
ex-cons in your house, and again, I have
no beef with ex-cons, but people have
perceptions, right? Uh if you have no
issues with ex-cons and you plan on
doing the packing yourself and you're
okay with them potentially breaking it
because they're not they're not insuring
anything, which honestly, it happens in
25% of moves.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you're the three out of four,
it's great. If you're the one out of
four, it's pretty tough.
>> Yeah.
>> Right? And if you have no cap and you
don't care that cuz I can come in at $10
now if you want, I'll just take a week.
>> [laughter]
>> That's fair.
>> Again, it's like we have to We have We
have to explain the whole the whole
system, right? And so what this is
called is I call it shifting from local
to global. Right? So like you're
thinking about this.
>> I am.
>> I'm thinking about this. Not me, but the
the consumer, right? And so all of a
sudden you give them way more variables
than they thought about because you know
more about it than they do. And that's
point of a good sales process. As
they're like, I didn't even think about
these things. And I was like, right.
That's okay. That's what education is
for. I'm educating you right now, right?
And so, this is what it sounds like you
really want, and that's what I can
deliver for you. Cuz at the end of the
day, if you get everything on time,
nothing breaks, you have a great
experience, I was like, is that worth
the extra 50 bucks?
>> My god, yes.
>> Right.
>> It's like
>> Oh, good. Good, man. So, this is what I
Once you walk through it, it's like,
this will get you the the deals you're
losing. You're losing to price because
they have nothing else to say.
They're doing apples to apples. You're
like, no, it's apples and oranges.
But it's totally fair that they're
they're charging less because they're
not doing all this stuff. Which, by all
means, if you want us to not do that
stuff, I can't because I have to have a
level of service and you see our
reviews. I'm not willing to I'm not
willing to sacrifice my reputation for
that. Some people are, though. Cuz
they're they're in and out of the
industry.
>> Yeah.
>> They they come in, they just they just
start moving, you know, for short
periods of time, and then they get out.
>> Yeah. I'm here for the long run.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Now that we have a better idea of what
our offers are, what we need to say is,
I would include we'll give them a free
VIP upgrade or free white glove, if you
want to use that term,
for anyone who you refer just so they
like think good things about you.
>> Okay.
>> They need to gain from referring you.
Their customer has to see them better
because they have the hookup, right?
People go to realtors because they're
you're supposed to know the area better,
and they've done this more times than
they have, right? If you knew
everything, you wouldn't need a realtor
cuz you already know the houses, you
already know how to do the deal,
>> [clears throat]
>> right?
So, saying, oh, my my guy I've got an
amazing moving moving company, they give
all my customers free upgrades. That
makes them look great,
right?
>> Got it. Okay. I love the offer. So, we
we did try um SMS, we also tried emails.
Emails did not get us absolutely zero
conversion.
>> That makes sense.
>> Yeah. So, SMS is what would give us some
traction, and then what we've been
trying lately is that we would just go
follow them on Instagram.
>> I think following and DMing would
probably have a higher conversion than
anything else.
>> we tried is that SMS, if absolutely any
response in a positive way, even like
liking the text, I would find that
person on Instagram, like go look them
up, and then follow them like, "Hey, I
saw you liked the message. Would love to
tell you more about what we have going
on."
>> I mean, I think start there, but I would
take that list,
feed it into AI,
and have an agent search online, find
the Instagram, and then follow them from
my account.
>> Okay.
>> And so, every day I would DM 10 or 20 of
them, because you can't you can only,
you know, DM so many. Now, if they
follow you back,
then you can DM as many times as you
want, right? So, we could do There's two
two two considerations. So, one is we
could say follow everyone, and then
anyone who follows you back, then you
DM. That's one option. Or, you just
automatically DM 10 or 20 cold
independent of whether they follow back.
>> Okay. So, you would actually do massive
outreach instead of just like picking up
the top 100 producers in San Diego?
>> I mean, we should do that. Should mean,
start there.
>> Yeah.
>> That's when my Okay. My wife could have
just up to actually take care of this
realtor.
>> So, you're going to do your SMS. This is
what you're currently doing. I don't
think you necessarily change any of
that. That's fine. The second is the
follow
to DM.
And I would say like, "Do you know
anyone? Uh we have a realtor
special,
which is VIP upgrade."
>> I like that word upgrade.
>> Yeah.
Or white glove, whatever you want to
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And so, that would be my auto DM back.
Now, the third thing that I would do,
because this is like
a lot of the realtor offices, the
brokerages, right? They have 5, 10, 20
agents, right? I would want to go to the
head of the brokerage and say, "Hey,
I'll do a brokerage level deal for you.
We'll give everyone who's an agent of
yours VIP, like for free, if we can just
be the first people people first people
you call when you have a move."
And ideally, it's like, "Can you
integrate us into your packet?" Because
that's the thing is like, they give
people packets for Right, exactly. So,
it's like, "I want to be the only one in
the list, and I'll give all of your
customers VIP upgrade. You can look at
our reviews, really good."
That's where, because you want
integration.
Because as soon as you get integrated in
their sales process, as long as you
could do a good job, they'll just
they're not going to look anywhere else.
>> Yeah. I have two that I can like
literally call up today and set up an
appointment for this upcoming like
tomorrow.
>> Yeah, cuz like one brokerage might sell
>> 20 agents.
>> Right. Well, yeah, 20 agents. And then
each agent might sell, you know, let's
say a house a quarter on average. I'm
just making it up, right? So, it's like
every brokerage is five houses a month.
>> Okay. That's $15,000.
>> Right.
>> On an average of 30 grand.
>> Per. Right? [laughter]
And so, it's like, okay, well, how many
brokerages are there? Plenty.
>> A lot.
>> Right. And so, I'd rather you sell one
to sell 60 a year.
>> Mhm.
>> Like that's what's worth your time. Like
let Jacob take the individual calls, but
you should be going out and getting the
brokerage who's going to get you 60
houses a year each. And then like every
week you bring another brokerage on, and
that means like every week you're
bringing another five deals a month on.
And it stacks.
>> Right.
>> And then what's going to the next bottom
neck is going to be you're not going to
be able to manage the relationships.
It's not there yet, but that's what's
going to happen. And so, you're going to
need to hire one person to full-time
manage the realtors.
>> Developer.
>> Yeah. Exactly. It's just a farmer.
>> My wife is going to be doing that for
now.
>> Great.
So, I think we target brokerages.
Because this is the long-term play. Like
you like it's good to have the reviews
you do, and that's going to continue to
compound and all that stuff.
>> [clears throat]
>> But, where I'd like you to get is in the
future at some point you start turning
deals down that are too small.
>> Like one bedrooms and small deliveries.
>> like, it's just not
>> And
>> We're not there.
>> Yeah.
>> I'd like you to get there. Because there
will be a day where you don't do deals
under 3K or under 5K.
Yeah.
>> They exist. I know. I I like trust me. I
I have to believe that they exist.
>> They do exist. I promise you.
Okay. So, we have our offer. We have our
VIP and our standard. Now, what's the
key thing to differentiate us? We
itemize all the elements inside of the
sales process. So, again, we can further
differentiate from the hourly. If we're
going to stick with hourly, then we
still have to have as many different
colors as we can here. All right?
>> Okay.
>> Then, um and also, I'm very flexible on
this. This might be able to be 225. Like
like continue to keep pushing this VIP
envelope until people stay say no, cuz
you always have your backup. You can
always fall back on a standard.
>> Standard, yeah.
>> But the people who have money will just
they'll spend more. It's just it's a
different monster.
Uh realtors we keep doing this, but I
think these two will give you more
leverage. This one is the biggest one.
>> Okay. Can I ask one question?
>> You want to show up in person here.
>> How many times?
>> Here's how I do it. This is the process.
Once you get any realtor thing, you need
to show up in person to their office to
meet all the other realtors in their
brokerage. Come come with donuts, come
with whatever. Meet the head guy and say
like, I had you know, I set up Kelly was
was that a good experience, Kelly?
Great. I can give every single one of
your agents VIP upgrades for all of our
moves for free. That's on me. Just cuz
she was so great to work with and it
gives you something that you can kind of
have as a as a nice experience.
>> Yeah.
Okay.
>> What was the question?
>> The question is about the SMS like cuz
now I have a list about 12,000 agents.
What do you think the first SMS should
be like? Is it should it keep it the
same or it doesn't really matter?
>> you're going to you're going to see what
the response rate is.
>> I wouldn't send the same thing to all of
them.
>> The smart cookie move
would be look up the agent.
AI can do all of this.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Do all of this AI can do.
>> I mean it's cloud, yeah.
>> Yeah. So, hook up
AI to the list, create an Excel sheet
that has personalized information.
>> Okay.
>> And then have a template for it to then
out output what you think or what it
thinks the personalized first text
should be and it'll give you the whole
list of all 100. You read them real
quick to make sure that they sound like
they make sense and click go.
>> Got it.
>> Cuz then they could all be personalized.
That's what I would test against just
the generic opener.
>> Got it.
>> And if you want to be wild, you could
probably Are you doing it from a you're
doing it from a true SMS, right?
>> No, I was using Mailchimp.
>> Is that does it have like a
an iPhone like a blue thing?
>> bubble, no.
>> Okay.
>> Would you recommend the blue bubble?
>> I would give it a shot. So, I would say
for
blue
bubble.
And I would say just test it cuz it's
going to be more,
but if you have a higher response rate,
then it's worth it.
>> With an With an area code that's local.
>> Yeah. And then five for this SMS here.
Oh, I got to put it up over here. Is AI
personalization
for that first message. It'll also make
it less likely that you get put into
spam.
>> Perfect.
>> Because if the carrier see you send that
same thing to 100 people,
they they spam the number. Yeah.
So, traffic. So, there's a couple couple
smaller things that I I think are worth
doing. So, right now, how are you
getting the reviews? What's the review
process?
>> So, as soon as we finish the move, the
guys just ask for a review immediately.
It would be doing me a huge favor. Takes
30 seconds. Helps us tremendously.
>> So, what's the script for the guys to
ask?
>> If you guys think we did a great job,
then would you mind leaving us a
five-star review? We'd highly appreciate
it. Takes 30 seconds.
>> So, I would just add one little piece
in,
which is um
there's probably a leader on each job
site, right?
>> So, the foreman goes over and says,
"Hey, um
you know, was this a good experience?"
If yes, "Okay, well, um
the guys get a little spiff from
ownership for five-star reviews. So, if
it if it means anything to you, it'd
mean a ton to those guys."
And then you can just take who got the
most reviews at the end of the month and
give 100 bucks. It doesn't matter. But
like, the likely that they'll just leave
a review, six out of 10. If it's like
these guys it actually makes a
difference for them, the likely that
they'll leave it way higher. And it's
better when it's not you cuz you can't
be like ownership. I mean, you can, but
like
>> Yeah. This is
>> Yeah, yeah. [laughter] Right.
>> That's true.
>> But it's easier for the foreman to just
be like,
uh the owner gives um an extra spiff to
the guys um if if they get a five-star.
>> Okay.
>> So, one is foreman review.
Foreman owner.
I'll say spiff. How about that?
>> Perfect.
>> And then two, do you do any social
media?
>> Barely.
>> Okay. So, I'll bet you you're losing
to people who have better socials than
you are because obviously search is one
thing, but the next thing you look at is
well, let me see if I can find these
people on social and that'll make a big
swing. And so,
can you maybe have the foreman do like a
before and after?
>> Um like house full and house empty?
>> Yeah. And then also, empty to full.
So, basically it's four it's it's before
after at site one, before after at site
two, clipped into one.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz you can just post those. Just before
and afters. And if you get the review,
put the five-star review at the end.
>> Got it. Okay.
>> So, it's like you're posting before and
after review. Before and after review.
Before and after review.
>> Got it. Okay.
>> So, the organic is before, right? After.
At site one, and then again,
before after at site two,
and then review.
So, it literally shows the full
Right. End to end. Like this is what it
was. This is what we did. This is where
we went. This is what happened. And they
said it was awesome.
>> Over and over and over and over again.
Okay.
>> Yeah. And then if you can,
I would get the realtor reviews cuz
that's going to matter more again for
um
And when I say reviews, I mean really
testimonials.
>> Like on a video.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah, I can I can definitely do
that. Yeah.
>> Yeah, and also, because the thing is is
the bigger the bigger your organic
following gets, right? When you go to
that brokerage and you say, "Hey, we're
good movers. We've been in the area for
a while. We just made a partnership with
XYZ Realty.
Um if you're looking to sell a house,
check it out." Like they love that. It's
free promotion for them and you just
throw it in if they do the deal with
you.
>> Beautiful.
>> Now, when you have 100,000 followers
that are local, makes a bigger
difference than when you have one. So,
cuz big picture,
if if we need the the business to grow,
right?
One is we're having a more premium
offer. So, for the people who want to
spend money, we allow them to do it.
Right?
>> And we're including things that other
people are not mentioning. Which are
these elements.
Which then when we get into the sales
process, we ask them no more questions,
but then we ask their preferences,
which they didn't think about, to
differentiate our our versus everyone
else's.
>> Mhm.
>> And then we can step down from VIP to
oh, you don't actually care about these
preferences. Oh, you're more on a budget
and you don't care about that stuff,
fine.
Cuz I promise you're not going to find
these things at a different price.
Got it.
Then with our realtors, we're adding in
the personalization for the AI. This is
going to be more lead gen.
This is going to be big, especially when
it's paired with these, right?
Brokerages is what I think you should
do.
This is the highest leverage thing that
you can do. Is you go and get 20 agents
at a time. As soon as you get one
realtor who responds back, I would go in
person.
Got it.
Because then it's like you don't just
get them, cuz they're already a unit
that can send you business every month.
But they have five other people or 20
other people in their brokerage that
would be what I would go. That's this is
my my big 20X lever. This is just to
enhance that. This is the this is the
smallest piece of this. I wouldn't even
obsess about it, but these are the
bigger ones. Got it.
So we can just boost the guys reviews,
just run the Spitfire.
And then from a long-term perspective,
we can build up our organic doing before
and afters
um in every single site with a review at
the end.
I think we do all this stuff.
This is going to be your
your biggest one.
That's the biggest lift for you. This is
probably going to be like this these
guys are going to be your second biggest
lift.
And then this whole sales process that I
outlined here is going to help you win
those other 40% of deals.
Long-term that'll compound too.
>> Thank you so much. Appreciate you.
>> Yeah, congrats.
All right, see here. So if we're looking
at where you're at on the scaling road
map, you're between three and four,
mostly on the four side cuz you got six
employees. You're acting as a manager,
right? It's your first full team.
And so from a product perspective, you
were saying yes to everyone who would
pay.
>> Yes. I mean, this spread, you know.
>> Right. No, you're good. This is the
transition. You were getting feedback
from different customers, so you were
like, oh, do I do the cheap thing or do
the expensive thing? I've got these very
different. So to graduate, we have to
specialize the product which creates our
V2 which is the VIP, and we price to
serve that richer customer.
>> Mhm. Score.
>> And just for for the magic of the
audience here, it's not like I I had
this and I wrote this after we talked.
>> No, I it put me here when I did the
whole thing with line. It put me here.
Yeah,
>> But now you're here, right?
>> Yeah.
>> From a marketing perspective, you're
talking to many unqualified leads, which
is what we're dealing with, and so we
have to make more content, which is what
we're doing on the before and after
side, right? And we're adding more
qualifications and friction, right?
Which goes into
these elements
of what we can do to kind of
differentiate what we're selling.
Which from a sales process, speed to
contact. Now, you haven't had a drop yet
cuz you still need to get more lead
volume in, right? And so we have to
start tracking a little bit more on this
side
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> than you probably are. Now, from a
customer success perspective, um you've
been doing fine, but as we scale,
quality is going to be that's going to
drop. And so to move from here to here,
we're going to have to have a quality
assurance loop that's going to happen.
That's not a problem yet, it's going to
be.
>> Okay.
Thank you so much.
>> Appreciate it. Thank you.
>> This is great. Thank you.
Just looking at back at all these other
business owners, looking at them, I'm
like, they're bigger, they're very
mature. I can't tell that they have
tapped into some pieces of life that I
haven't gotten to.
>> And do you for sure [music]
think that Naz has youth on his side, so
full of energy, and so full of [music]
optimism and excitement, and definitely
strikes me as an action taker.
>> He was very positive, [music] very
enthusiastic, and very young. That was
my first impression.
>> His his niche is super accessible,
especially where he's at, so I think he
can he can really have a lot of success
in what he's doing.
>> I think the biggest advantage that I
have out of everybody is that I'm small
enough that I could grow the fastest.
>> [applause]
>> THE IDEA BEHIND THIS is who do we want
to scale with over the next year versus
necessarily where someone could
potentially kind of fall off. The
business is very straightforward.
I think the
biggest thing that I don't like about
the business is I hate selling hourly
with a vicious passion.
And so I would do everything in my power
to
transition to only these realtors and
only selling by job so that we can get
out of this kind of like rat race and
dealing with these high volume kind of
BS. Also the competitors that are going
to compete at the bottom aren't going to
be legit and the customers you're
selling to aren't going to appreciate
the difference because they are truly
bargain shopping and they might not have
things of value. So they might not care
if they break and things like that.
I
Dude, my heart can't do it.
I honestly can't do it.
I'm supposed to scale or fail
and the fail has nothing to do with
whether or not the business will fail.
This plan will succeed. The reason that
I particularly wouldn't want to do it
yet is because I think you're too far
away from getting to multiple locations,
which is where I would gain more
interest. Does that make sense?
And so for only the purpose of our big
big term discussion
I will fail.
But from a short term angle
you're going to do great, dude.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, this this will work. Once you
get this dialed and you can move up the
avatar, this is one step towards not
selling for hourly and we can start
selling packages, we can start selling
turn key moves. That's where this
becomes more interesting and you can
start getting into new markets with a
clear differentiated product, which then
will allow you to really scale.
Cool?
>> Sounds great.
>> appreciate you so much. Appreciate you.
Thank you.
>> The one moment where I really felt like
we were going to scale is when we
mentioned the realtors and how much
value we could get out of it in the next
few months.
Um but the moment when I knew it could
be a fail is when I said in the very
beginning the goal is to grow to
multiple locations. That was really
stupid of me. I probably shouldn't have
said that at at all, but it is what it
is and we're just going to take the plan
and work through it. The way I feel
right now is I feel
I feel amazing. At the end of the day,
it's his opinion. Uh I'm very tenacious,
so I'm just going to go back, take that
plan that he just put on that beautiful
white piece of paper, and we're going to
go ahead and execute it for the next 90
days.
And let's see how we do.
And we'll we'll we'll scale the
business. We will absolutely scale the
business.
>> Physically, it's like
I want to be able to apply what we're
good at to the business that can get the
most out of it. And all of these things
have to happen in the model for it to
kind of get nailed before it can scale.
And so right now I think he's in the
nail-it phase more than the scale-it
phase. And so that's why all of these
changes are really nailing the model
before we scale it.
>> To be fully transparent, I really did
not have any expectations. Was I really
surprised? Just a little bit. So, in the
next 90 days, I have already put a plan.
I have already talked to somebody to get
a second truck since we've been getting
more of the bigger jobs with the
realtors. My wife is that's that's what
she does all day now. It's just realtors
implementing with AI.
So,
>> [music]
>> yeah, as soon as I go back, uh I'm
I'm going to have to tell my wife
the truth. Can't lie to her. Um
I'm sorry.
I did not
I did not think this would be like this.
Honestly,
had they not come here,
the business would have grown a little
bit, but not at the level it's about to
be
to be launched. And the reason why it's
because I always keep this thing in my
[music] heart every single time somebody
says, "You can't do this thing."
Sorry, I'm getting a little bit
emotional there.
Every single time, every single time
somebody said I [music] couldn't do
certain things, I would just go and do
it faster and better and stronger every
single time. But I really think that
Roadmap is absolutely priceless.
Priceless. Cuz we'll make that in again
$100,000 that we didn't get, we'll make
it in 2 months even before this guy
comes back to the show. Maybe he'll
change his mind.
>> [laughter]
>> So, two things. One, I I reference the
Scaling Roadmap. Wherever you're at, you
should check out where on there like
it's pretty spot on and it's because
businesses are not as unique as we think
they are.
Patterns exist across all of them. So,
that thing's free, you can go grab it.
But inside my Offers book,
um I talk about I think the first
chapter is that you're selling a
commodity, the commodity problem. And if
a customer can look at two things and
say these are the same, they will always
take the cheaper item. And so, our goal
as business owners, unless your entire
strategy is to be the cheapest, which is
you want to compete in the commodities
game and you built your whole business
to be cheaper than everyone else, unless
that's your goal, which it rarely is and
it probably shouldn't be for service,
then you want to be on the other side of
the spectrum, which is you want to be
the value leader. And value leader is
thinking about all the different
components that a customer and all the
problems that you could potentially
solve for a customer, break them down
kind of like I just did, and say, "Okay,
these are all the elements that a
customer is not thinking about, but once
I present them, they realize that these
are actually two very different things,
which then allows us to price for the
right customer at a much more premium
price." Thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next Scalar Fail.
Next time on Scalar Fail.
>> I'm M Jenkynson and I teach crafters how
to make stickers.
>> If you double the amount of customers
you have, does it break anything?
>> No.
>> Okay. So, this is a pure demand issue.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> This would be a higher risk test, but
one that I would strongly consider.
>> I'm not risk averse.
>> Okay.
>> We won't be talking hundreds.
>> We have to. How many stickers do people
make?
>> Oh, thousands.
>> Question is, do I want to spend a year
working with you to scale this, or do I
think there's something that's going to
get in the way?
So, the verdict is